Donald Trump's Senate impeachment trial
is underway sort of but not really we
actually streamed hours and hours of
yesterday's proceedings which went into
the night and it was in a sense the
start of Donald Trump's impeachment
trial but I say not really because it
was filled merely with amendment
proposals and debates and subsequent
tabeling by Republicans of those
amendments by Democrats all about how is
impeachment going to be done and one of
the big arguments was over to catch you
up like if you missed everything if you
missed what was that eight hours I don't
know how long it went yesterday if you
missed all of those hours you really
didn't miss very much it was one of the
big arguments was Republicans want to
deal with documents and witnesses after
both sides have had 24 hours each to
make their arguments and after the
hundred senators have had 16 hours to
ask questions of the prosecutors and the
defenders this would be like in a
criminal trial saying documents at would
and witnesses no no first we want both
sides to make all of their arguments
we'll give the jury a chance to
deliberate and come back with questions
if they have any and then after all of
that is done we'll discuss whether any
witnesses are going to testify including
witnesses to the alleged crimes that are
being adjudicated here
it's a laughingstock it's a farce it's a
joke of a trial if you do it that way so
Democrats ended up in the impossible
position of having to propose amendments
to deal with at least the document piece
now or of sitting back and allowing
Republicans to just say we're gonna deal
with documents and witnesses later and
implicitly saying that that's okay by
not putting forth amendments to try to
change that so Democrats proposed an
amendment to subpoena documents from the
White House now they debated that
amendment nearly two hours and then of
course Republicans have a majority
Republicans voted to table or put off
that decision with a 53 to 47 party line
vote saying we'll deal with documents
after the trial
so then Chuck Schumer stands up the
Senate Minority Leader and
poses another amendment this time to
subpoena documents from the State
Department and of course the exact same
results 53 to 47 Republicans say we
already have a process of marbled
marble-mouthed Mitch McConnell stood up
and says we're going to be dealing with
documents and witnesses after 48 and
1664 hours of testimony our arguments
and questions we'll deal with it later
53 to 47 Republicans table it so then
Democrats say we have an amendment we
want to subpoena chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney or no next was a documents from
the OMB and then we want a subpoena Mick
Mulvaney then we want to subpoena the
documents from the Defense Department we
want a subpoena Robert Blair Mulvaney's
a senior adviser we want a subpoena
Michael Duffy the OMB z' Associate
Director for national security we want
to subpoena national security advisor
john bolton we'll talk about that later
and of course democrats can't win those
amendments because they don't have the
votes but they can't just stay silent
about this atrocity being committed by
republicans led by Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell so they have to
do the logical and obvious thing which
is we don't agree with the process we
don't agree with 64 hours of proceedings
before we debate which documents and
witnesses will be admitted so they have
no choice but to introduce these
amendments every single one of which was
of course tabled by Republicans
eventually senators approved a roadmap
for impeachment for the trial which
Mitch McConnell laid out and again
Democrats don't have the numbers but the
important parameters are that each side
will have 24 hours to present opening
arguments Mitch McConnell wanted each
side to have two days for those 24 hours
that's 12 hours a day that is a
Republican strategy to have insanely
late-night stuff going on which way
fewer people would see they were able to
get Republicans to say ok we can spread
the 24 hours over three days meaning it
won't go as late into the night any
another sort of compromise is that
subpoenas for witnesses and documents
will be debated
after opening arguments so understand
the insanity of this what Republicans
wanted was to have 24 hours of opening
arguments from one side 24 hours of
opening arguments from the other side
and 16 hours of questions from senators
and then to debate subpoenas and
witnesses subpoenas of documents and
witnesses what they've Democrats wanted
to do it right now which makes sense
what they've agreed upon is they will do
the 48 hours of opening arguments then
debate subpoenaing documents and
witnesses a small concession but a
concession nonetheless and then all of
the house evidence the stuff that came
up during the intelligence and the
judiciary hearings that will all be
automatically part of the Senate trial
unless someone objects rather than
having to introduce bits of evidence and
testimony piece by piece okay only water
and milk were allowed into the Senate
chamber there was a rule of silence
during yesterday's proceedings which led
to senators flashing almost like flash
cards flashing pieces of paper with
notes on them to each other crazy so
today is day two I hope you'll again
join me for a live stream on YouTube and
twitch yesterday's live stream saw
nearly a hundred thousand different
people join us over the course of the
afternoon and evening we'll be back at
it today here's what to watch for today
do Donald Trump's lawyers respond with
any substance yesterday Adam Schiff and
the other Democratic impeachment
managers were talking about substance
and meanwhile Trump's lawyers Pat sip
Bologna and Jay Sekulow talked about
circumstances they talked about we
weren't invited to things that they
actually were invited to they talked
about Joe Biden they talked about
everything other than the actual
substance of the allegations so question
one for today's will they talk about
substance I predict no number two today
there's going to be a whole new round of
motions including more than likely
motions by Republicans to dismiss the
entire case against Donald Trump Trump
wildly suggested that the entire
impeachment trial should simply be
canceled on Twitter a couple of weeks
ago and we know that when Donald Trump
says jump Republicans say how high and
that
is likely something they will do today
argue the entire case should just be
cancelled by the time you hear this
segment or watched today's show we will
likely know whether they've submitted
such motions because they're doing
writing before they actually start if
you were wondering this seems like a lot
of sidebar when will the actual
substantive arguments begin we don't
know it could happen later this week
Friday could be Saturday they do plan to
go six days a week the substance may not
even start until early next week it's
going to be very long Donald Trump will
be acquitted at the end unless something
completely beyond our ability to predict
happens and the most important message
is this one yesterday you had people on
both sides Democrats and Donald Trump's
lawyers arguing that if this is not a
full and fair trial it's not good for
anyone in other words the argument was
if people don't believe if the public
doesn't believe that this is a fair
trial an acquittal isn't very powerful
and a conviction isn't very powerful
they are wrong given that an acquittal
is all but a foregone conclusion only
half the country really cares about a
fair trial this won't be a fair trial
there may or may not be witnesses it
will be a sham in which Republicans have
already prejudged and we know they will
vote to acquit
but trumpets would be fine with that
when they say unless this is a full and
fair trial an acquittal of Donald Trump
isn't worth very much wrong trumpets
will see the eventual acquittal as an
exoneration and then they will say look
Trump did nothing wrong he was
exonerated so where I completely
disagree with what has been argued from
both sides Adam Schiff argued this and
also Trump's lawyers argued this Trump
doesn't need a fair trial for his
acquittal to be accepted his followers
will accept the acquittal as an
exoneration no matter what kind of a
kangaroo court ends up rendering that
verdict let's now focus in on one
witness John Bolton